[Musique]
deux verrières des murs rouges et deux
salles vides qui invite à lever les yeux
vers le ciel pain au plafond c'est ici
que gustave courbet avait choisi
d'installer son atelier d'ornans le
dépouillement des lieux est un choix
délibéré de l'architecte qui a présidé à
leur restauration le lieu se suffit à
lui-même il porte la trace du passé la
trace de courbet lui-même avec ce
fabuleux décors peints ou encore jugé
pas pertinent de
recréer une atmosphère peut-être plus
artificiel pour les visiteurs la courbe
et a décidé de peindre sur du plâtre qui
étaient déjà à sec donc ce qui
conditionne aussi l'état de sauvegarde
de la peinture puisque c'est beaucoup
plus fragile d'une fresque malgré les
affres du temps l'humidité des lieux
dédiés pendant tant d'années au stockage
du vin les deux peintures murales ont pu
être sauvés la scène à bougival d'un
côté une vue de l'escaut se jetant à la
mer de l'autre deux panorama peints par
l'artiste pour décorer ce lieu qu'il
avait fait construire en pleine nature
il faut imaginer que cet atelier était
implantée au coeur de la campagne en
dehors de la ville et que courbet avait
acheté l'ensemble des terrains
environnants
jusqu'aux falaises calcaires au nord qui
s'étendait jusqu'à la lie au sud c'est
là que courbet a peint l'hallali du cerf
c'est là qu'il recevait ses amis
accumulé des objets entreposés ses
oeuvres comme ce merveilleux bronze
exposé temporairement dans l'actuel
musée et que l'on devine sur cette photo
de 1864 mais au delà de l'histoire de
l'un des plus grands artistes du 19e
siècle
c'est la possibilité d'imaginer le
peintre dans ses murs qui provoque
d'indicible émotions
[Musique]